[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
les territoires gronde les villes les
départements les régions
tous ont semble-t-il quelque chose à
redire sur l'action et les choix du
gouvernement il est beaucoup question
d'argent dans cette affaire pour en
débattre
un député de la république en marche
didier parisse bonjour joue député de
côte-d'or ajoutons que vous connaissez
bien fonctionnement du conseil régional
vous avez exercé une partie de votre
carrière jérôme durain bonjourbonjour
sénateur socialiste de saône et loire et
président du groupe majoritaire au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté
bonjour maffre idaomar un jour vous êtes
président des maires de l'yonne sans
étiquette politique et mr vous-même de
valve ravillon une nouvelle commune
issue d'un regroupement et c'est rare et
puis françois xavier dugourd bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le premier
vice-président les républicains du
conseil départemental de côte-d'or pour
ouvrir le débat il y a une vraie
question c'est qui dit vrai les
présidents des associations
collectivités villes départements et
régions se plainent la cour des comptes
il ya deux jours dit les finances des
collectivités s'améliore gérald darmanin
le ministre 17 budget de plus favorable
aux collectivités depuis dix ans alors
moi j'ai envie de vous dire que qu'est
ce qu'on fait là jérôme durain est ce
qu'il ya vraiment un problème de
finances des collectivités
je pense que le sujet plus important que
ce que vous dites que votre question
évoque la question c'est le rapport de
l'état et de ce gouvernement avec les
territoires
est ce qu'on se dit la mondialisation la
start-up nacion les métropoles
et puis les territoires on verra après
ou est ce qu'on se dit nos territoires
ont quelque chose à apporter à la
cohésion nationale
à la croissance de l'économie et je
pense qu'on a un vrai sujet avec un
tropisme de monsieur macron une
orientation qui est quand même très
urbaine très internationale est assez
peu tourné vers les territoires ruraux
ayant pourtant un président élu sur
aussi la rigueur budgétaire la
résorption des déficits il est normal
que cette résorption des déficits elle
s'exerce aussi sur les collectivités qui
avec la décentralisation aujourd'hui
exerce une part importante de l'activité
du pays oui enfin avec les choix fiscaux
qui sont proposés et cette étiquette qui
va lui coller longtemps je le crains de
président des riches
avec cette inégalité fiscale qui est
proposé est évidemment quand on quand on
perd 5 milliards d'un côté sur les plus
riches du pays
il faut aller chercher l'argent ailleurs
et on va faire la poche de connectivité
via paris 10 milliards annoncée
d'économies pendant la campagne
finalement 13 demandé est ce que ces
présidents des villes qui prend de
l'argent sur les territoires comme le
bio moi je comprends pas ce débat
ville-campagne à mon avis il est il est
instrumentalisé la mf fait ce qu'il faut
pour ça non la réalité c'est que la
france doit continuer son nez ses
efforts budgétaires cet impératif
l'objectif d' emmanuel macron ces cinq
points de moins de dette publique
trois points de moins de dépenses
publiques et un point de moins de
prélèvements obligatoires
pourquoi parce que on est en train
depuis longtemps y compris les
collectivités mais pas qu'elle l'état en
général on a dépensé ce qu'on avait pas
aujourd'hui il s'agit de moins dépenser
et de faire en sorte qu'on soit qu'on
soit dans nos objectifs économiques de
la france je vous rappelle quand même
que un point d'intérêt c'est la moitié
du budget de l'éducation nationale en
france peut pas continuer comme ça on
peut pas durablement avoir une situation
où on dépense comme ça en maintenant
c'est vrai que je comprends la situation
des collègues est derrière l'idée que
les collectivités goberge avec l'argent
de l'état et que donc on peut tailler
dedans ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui et
c'est vraiment conscience de l'action
c'est changer le mode relationnel ça a
été évoqué par jérôme changer le mode
relationnel
on est dans un rapport qui doit être
maintenant un rapport de responsabilité
contractuelle entre l'état et les
collectivités 13 millions vous ai raison
c'est beaucoup mais c'est pas
près de 13 milliards dont bien
évidemment c'est beaucoup mais c'est pas
contrairement à ce qui se passait avant
13 milliards de diminution de 2
d'intervention de l'état
la dgf dotation globale de
fonctionnement et l'ensemble des
dotations ne subira aucune modification
et c'est l'indication de budgets très
clair ce que nous souhaitons c'est tout
simplement que les collectivités pères
prennent leur part une réduction de
dépenses de 13 mire l'état dans le même
temps réduira ses dépenses de 81
milliard 80 milliards c'est pas une
c'est pas un effort qui n'est demandé
que collectivité ce un effort collectif
que nous devons assumer français la
rigueur budgétaire
c'est vrai public à ce que vous avez
longtemps demandé gouvernement gauche
donc ça doit vous plaire
la rigueur on se l'appliquent déjà dans
nos collectivités
que ce soit les régions les départements
les communes depuis un certain nombre
d'années l'état ses plus récents en tout
cas c'est une volonté exprimée on va
voir ce dans les faits ce qui est
certain c'est que l'été était
particulièrement meurtrier pour les
collectivités territoriales qui ont il
ya eu une succession de mesures prises
particulièrement virulente
les dotations de l'état on en a parlé
mais aussi la chute des contrats aidés
les la taxe d'habitation les menaces sur
le logement social
c'est pourquoi en parler enfin tout ça
fait que les collectivités qui était
déjà malmenée sous françois hollande
aujourd'hui sont asphyxiés sous emmanuel
macron mais au delà ça le plus grave je
pense c'est la question de la confiance
entre l'état et des collectivités
territoriales parce que emmanuel macron
réuni à la mi-juillet la conférence
nationale des territoires très bien on
va travailler en confiance en
contractualisant parfait sauf que
quelques jours après ils annoncent des
mesures complètement contradictoire avec
ce qu'il venait de dire tant commandes
la confiance peut s'instaurer entre
l'état et les élus ça me semble
fondamental est également la visibilité
sur la cour des comptes ya deux jours
il ya moins de départements en
difficulté qu'il n'y en avait avant donc
est ce que vous décrivez correspond à la
réelle mais parce que les départements
ont fait des efforts considérables ces
dernières années au détriment des
communes pas tout à tous les favoris au
détriment des communes pas tous les
départements faudra poursuivre et oui
alors déjà je voudrais dire que sur sur
la dette
80% de la dette c'était la dette de
l'état et 20 % la dette c'était la dette
de des collectivités seulement donc
aujourd'hui on nous demande de faire des
efforts très importants mais et c'est
normal que les c'est normal que nous en
fassions des efforts mais au départ 80 %
de la dette
c'est l'état il faudrait quand même les
5% sur les communes 5% sur les
collectivités
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on fait
payer aux collectivités les dépenses qui
ont été faites par l'état
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important alors on veut bien nous
collectivités participer à l'effort oui
mais ce que l'on n'accepte pas et on l'a
dit tout à l'heure ce que je n'accepte
pas c'est quand on parle de pacte de
confiance avec les collectivités
on parle de discussion pacte c'est à
dire qu'il ya discussion et confiance ça
veut dire qu'on est en toute confiance
et quand on lui dit 12 10 milliards et
que quelques jours à prendre du 10 13
milliards ça nous pose quand même un
problème parce que derrière ce qu'il ne
faut pas oublier c'est que cet argent
qu'il faut économiser
ça correspond à des services dans les
communes
ça correspond à des choses qui sont
concrètes ça correspond à des cantines
scolaires
ça correspond à des personnes âgées à
des services aux personnes âgées
ça correspond à tout ça et si vous
laissez ça fait l'avocat du diable est
ce que ça veut dire qu'on s'est payé des
cantines scolaires ou des services aux
personnes âgées qu'on n'avait pas les
moyens de se payer en france je n'en
savais volontairement viola ça veut dire
que les gens les gens paient moins cher
ses services là parce que y'a les
collectivités qui sont là parce que si
vous voulez les gens peuvent pas payer
10 euros 7 euros 8 euros un repas donc
ça veut dire qu'on participe à ça ça
veut dire que demain c'est cspj cela
qu'ils vont être perdus et qui vous et
qui vous vous savez aujourd'hui
moi quand je vous quand j'entends
monsieur pâris nous dire quand j'entends
monsieur pâris nous dire c'est normal et
c'est ils étaient des gs du conseil
régional je veux dire je crois que quand
ils étaient des ges du conseil régional
et si aujourd'hui il est encore des
gestes du conseil régional avec 450
millions de moins
je peux vous assurer qu'ils réagiraient
pas bien des façons on va dire que les
450 millions c'était un fonds
supplémentaires pour le développement
économique c'est pas si tu es parti sur
les budgets précédents comme juste à
amos 2 c'est par ici
on vient de lui demander comment il
aurait fait s'il est de regarder s de la
région et ensuite géré en mesure agir
sur on parle de confiance voulzy résout
pas ce que 3 milliards d'un constat
lourd quand même pour les collectivités
qui sortent de l'été on parle de
confiance et vous avez raison ce qui se
passe quand même c'est que et vous
l'avez dit lilian melet le rapport de la
cour des comptes il est tout récent il
dit les collectivités ont reconstitué
des capacités de financement de 4,2
milliards d'euros
c'est même supérieure à la baisse qu'on
a connus de la dgf
donc ça veut dire que tout n'est pas
tout n'est pas simple et tout n'est pas
acté mais ça veut dire quand même
interisti ce menteur des mondes
pardonnez moi je finis donc on a quand
même un redressement progressif l'an
inégale suivant les collectivités ça y'a
aucun doute inégal mais quel est le quel
est le principe aujourd'hui que le
président et le gouvernement
souhaiterait mettre en place c'est assez
simple on arrête la diminution est de on
arrête la diminution des dotations
collective qui est sont maintenus par
contre on rentre dans un jeu de
confiance vous avez évoqué interne qui
consistera après la diminution des 13e
journée aussi attendez je pense que là
c'est le moment de rappeler
il ne s'agit pas d'une diminution de 13
milliards de dotations en aucune façon
contrairement à ce que certains élus
sûrement pas ici parce que vous êtes
responsable mais m à faire quoi il ne
s'agit pas de diminution de dotation il
s'agit juste de dire sur cinq ans l'état
va économiser 80 milliards et les
collectivités territoriales devraient
économiser 13 milliard pour 5 i love
attention grosse différence avec ce que
nous avons ce que nous avons connu c'est
que jusqu'à maintenant moche premier à
le reconnaître les coups de rabot
c'était des coups de rabot un peu aller
tout le monde y passe et ça n'est plus
le petit qui est pressée simplement
c'est cette demande tendancielle par
rapport à par rapport aux mots au budget
antérieur va essentiellement s'appliquer
sur qui sur les grandes collectivités
or ça et on va y venir là trois sondés
sur les téléphones initialement
impactera en aucune façon les petites et
moyennes contre pas de baisses de
dotations nous dit-on d'accord mais on a
quand même pris 400 millions dans les
agences de l'eau 127 millions chez le
budget du sport 140 au département 142
pour les amendes de police 150 au
métropole
ah ça fait quand même beaucoup s'il ya
une baisse de notation exemple les 94
nouveaux germes de provocation ça va 450
millions d'euros pour les régions de
quoi s'agit-il
la loi de finances la dernière avait dit
il ya une compensation à opérer sur les
transferts économique au département
l'état s'engage le budget voté 450
millions d'un trait de crayon ou et la
confiance l'état annuler ses 450
millions ici en région bourgogne franche
comté c'est 20 millions d'euros qu'on va
perdre alors didier parisse te connais
ce budget de la région il l'a préparée
il disait tout à l'heure on a dépensé ce
qu'on n'allait pas on a dépensé ce qu'on
n'avait pas mais qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est
ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a dépensé
inutilement il ya deux jours une session
conseil régional 100 millions pour le
tourisme 15 millions pour l'agriculture
au lieu de 5 millions d investissements
dans l'économie partout on fait comme si
les collectivités ça n'était pas les que
l'économie réelle
comme si ce n'était pas la croissance
comme si ce n'était pas la condition de
la croissance dans les territoires on
est des territoires on est de l'autre
très haut débit on aide aux services
publics pour que les entreprises
s'installent il faut que tout ça donc
quand on dépense en euros en région
c'est un euro qui est productif
c'est pas de l'argent qui est ce
praticien la version n'ya pas steve et
que la fusion toute façon à générer des
gains on ajuste agglomérés les régions
donc vous pouvez gagner les sous là
dessus les personnels immobilier les
choses comme ça je sais ce qu'on a
entendu moi j'ai souvenir du débat entre
droite et gauche et front national à la
région on a entendu ces choses là
donc est ce qu'il n'ya pas ça aussi dans
les langues
or ce fait des économies c'est pas pour
avoir un petit matelas de côté si on
fait des économies c'est pour le
réinvestir dans les territoires et
partout où on gagne 1 euro c'est un euro
qui doit être productif parce qu'on nous
demande des maisons de santé on nous
demande des routes on nous demande du
ferroviaire
on nous demande du très haut débit il
faut investir donc chaque fois qu'on a
un euro ont investi et quand l'argent
fait défaut quand l'état fait défaut et
bien c'est le service public disparaît
dans les territoires histoire
fonctionnement parce que là on parle
d'investissements mais on parle beaucoup
il yal idée du fonctionnement aussi des
collectivités du très bonne question
donc dans l'état d'esprit général
globalement les collectivités c'est des
grands immeubles super beau avec plein
de personnels région pour être franche
comté nos vices présidents partagent
leurs bureaux au même pas un bureau par
personne on a moins de 5% du budget qui
consacré au fonctionnement moins de 5%
sur 1 milliard 5
donc là on est à l'os et je crois pas
venez la région il n'y a pas de dépenses
somptuaires je venais que ce recours il
ya plein de dépenses somptuaires
six millions de français qui habitent
dans la ruralité 26 millions donc ça
veut bien dire que c'est quand même une
partie de la france qu'on peut pas
négliger
ils ont le même ils ont le même objectif
que tout le monde y veulent ils veulent
s'est levé comme tous les français
ils veulent aller vers le destin commun
mais de toute façon mais en quoi
demander des économies aux collectivités
c'est mépriser le monde rural
pardonnez-moi mais est-ce qu'on mélange
pas à des fins politiques aussi deux
sujets non parce que alors déjà il faut
savoir qu'une les dotations de l'état
elles sont grosso modo deux à trois fois
plus importante quand on est sûrs d'un
que quand on est rural saas etc
c'est une évidence si vous voulez si
c'est vrai qu'il ya des charges de
centralité dans les dents les dans les
villes mais il ya des charges de
ruralité en campagne le territoire et
vont plus beaucoup plus grand et je peux
vous assurer que moi je rencontre tous
les jours des verts tous les jours je
rencontre des élus et je peux vous
assurer que si seulement envers dans
cette france dans cette vraie france
c'est pas le monde d'avant le monde de
demain c'est la france d'aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe exactement aujourd'hui
concrètement l'argent est leur manque
pour faire quoi
un maire rural là en ce moment il lui
manque pour faire quoi vous savez ils
ont ils ont des idées ils ont envie de
faire des choses pour qu'il ya un lien
social qui se créent dans le village ils
ont besoin de moyens ils ont ils
demandent pas des ils demandent pas des
mille et des cents mais je disais tout à
l'heure
je vois ma collectivité mois qu'une une
communauté de communes de 12000
habitants -36% de dotation en cinq ans
je dis bien moins 36% et là on parle pas
des 10 milliards et des 13 milliards 1
c'est moins 36% ou je risque avaient été
prélevés par ses débordements précédent
enfin mais c'est vrai que les élus ont
des difficultés aujourd'hui parce que
ils sont à semer de norne
il faut le dire aussi à sauver de
contraintes des réformes qui se sont
succédé depuis des années et puis
s'ajoute aujourd'hui les problèmes
financiers et aujourd'hui être mère être
élu dans les territoires en particulier
ruraux c'est particulièrement compliquée
et et c'est vrai qu'on a eu on est à
l'os et il a derrière ça c'est de
service public dont j'entendais
dernièrement le président du syndicat
national des directeurs généraux de
service donc c'est gauche-droite un
essai pas des élus qui disait nous c'est
terminé on peut plus assurer les
services de base à la population
ça veut dire très concrètement qu on
pourrait avoir des diminutions des
horaires d'entrée dans les piscines
c'est des services concrets la
population qui vont être moins rendu par
par cette cette politique alors sur les
départements met donc vous le sauriez de
l'accord juste pour pousser votre
logique jusqu'au bout pour que l'état
français résorbe - son déficit public
pour pouvoir continuer à voir ses
horaires d'ouverture des piscines il
faut que l'état ait des républicains
les boucles était engagé une vraie
réforme
une vraie réforme de l'état parce que
les économies et doivent être au gie
aussi fait sur les tares et aujourd'hui
honnêtement et n'est pas engagée dans
les collectivités c'est que le mouvement
est engagé depuis longtemps
je prends un exemple sur les
départements pour illustrer les
départements ont la compétence sociale
fondamentale pour nous une compétence
très noble petite enfance personnes
âgées personnes handicapées
c'est 50 % du budget des départements
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche
aujourd'hui on est acculé à une
politique qui est défini par l'état les
départements n'ont pas les leviers
puisque les allocations sont fixés les
montants sont fixés par l'état et
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que les
collectivités les départements reste à
charge pour les départements 43 % du
budget de ces aides sociales
or la décentralisation avait prévu le
transfert et la compensation intégrale
par l'état de ces transferts de
compétences aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est les collectivités qui
doivent assumer par le fisc
et malheureusement ce que l'état ne fait
plus ça veut dire ça veut dire quoi
parce que notre système marche pas comme
décentralisation et salissures et
centralisée ce jusque là on parle à la
fois via le budget de l'état médias de
la politique derrière tout ça ou si on
le sait bien et est ce que quand on
parle services publics etc on le mélange
avec de la politique et ce qu'on fait
pas une erreur et est ce que ça montre
pas l'immaturité de la france pour son
système décentralisé
parce que moi j'ai quand même souvenir
de la gauche dans les régions en 2004
expliquant que la décentralisation
marchait pas que l'état ne leur donnait
pas l'argent et que le transfert de
compétences marchait pas à chaque
alternance politique on entend la même
chose et vous dit de service public
est ce qu'on peut vraiment faire et de
la politique et du service public il ya
pas de vridi centre a dit j'accepte en
réalité on étende la centralisation
c'est à dire que on décentralise les
compétences et on centralise l'argent
exactement la réalité c'est ça vous
voulez quoi vous voulez lever l'impôt
je remuerai une des bonnes réformes qui
a été fait on va donner un exemple très
concret
le contribuable paye ses impôts l'état
redistribue l'argent
il ya plusieurs façons de le faire soit
on est dans le régime des dotations donc
l'état donne donne un peu moins reprend
redonne donne d'une main reprend de
l'autre
soit on a une autonomie financière
réelle
manuel valls étant le dernier
quinquennat avait autorisé les régions à
percevoir une part de tva et ça c'est un
bon moyen de travailler parce que les
collectivités ne sont pas suspendues au
bon vouloir de l'état qui tient ou ne
tient pas ses promesses
en revanche elles savent sur quoi elles
peuvent compter ça donne plusieurs
choses
ça donne une stabilité de gestion ça
donne une lisibilité de l'activité et on
n'est pas soumis sept allers-retours
incessants et là on n'est pas obligé de
faire de la petite politique parce que
on sait avec quoi on travaille et pour
le citoyen également une visibilité par
rapport à par rapport à l'impôt et papa
bon celui qu'il dépendance alors ça
pourrait être ça le nouveau
fonctionnement parce que c'est pas ça te
propose si la contractualisation c'est
juste ce qui est onlylyon mais pardonnez
moi mais c'est que quand j'entends quand
j'entends mais mes collègues ils disent
très exactement ce que le gouvernement
souhaite mettre en place
en considérant que c'est une mauvaise
idée alors il faudrait savoir où on est
faudrait savoir où on est premiers
éléments chaque collectivité doit
assumer ses compétences petites et
grandes rurale ou urbaine ya aucun doute
là dessus
deuxième élément il faut qu'on sorte de
cette idée de la dotation d'état fait
tout vous avez raison on peut pas
continuer comme ça raison pour laquelle
on est sur une base contractuelle est
l'exemple de la région vous avez évoqué
ce pas moi qui on parle mais franchement
c'est très caractéristique quand
j'entends jérôme durain dire il ya des
réalités économiques certes il ya des
réalités économiques ce que nous voulons
faire c'est tout simplement transférer
une partie substantielle des dotations
en fractions la tva qu'est ce qu'il ya
de plus dynamique qu'une fraction de la
tva à un moment où la france est en
train de se relever
c'est dans ce projet à savoir bien sûr à
la loi de finances gène documents s'ils
voulaient et c'est extrêmement clair il
y avait une dotation exceptionnelle
exceptionnel ça veut dire ce que ça veut
dire
on est on est en france et les mots ont
un sens dotation exceptionnelle et par
compte
une frappe mais parce que on réorganise
l'ensemble du système
cette campagne l'an passé soit en soit
le responsable
donc on reprend sur des dotations qui
sont donc outils pour y répondre les à
la fraction tva dynamique oui oui mais
attendez juste mais c'est intéressant
avec néanmoins l'idée que si une manière
d'aider les collectivités territoriales
c'est d'aider l'économie locale
c'est d'aidé à l'innovation c'est
d'aider au développement c'est tout ce
qui se joue en ce moment sur rien
la loi travail c'est tout ce qui se joue
surtout nécessaire alors que j'ai vu les
gens vous fait rien d'autre
il ya quand même par exemple si on prend
l'exemple des départements des façons de
faire très disparates dans les
départements par exemple si on pense à
haut débit à l'internet et je pourrai
regarder mahfoud a eu marre parce qu'on
sait que l'yonne est un département qui
a commencé très très tard à investir
dans le haut débit
donc quand vous dites on fait pas autre
chose tous les départements toutes les
communes n'ont pas fait entendre avec
l'argent avec l'argent de l'état parce
qu'en l'occurrence sécher leurs
scénarios si c'est aussi une vie aussi
nos propres crédits parce que les
départements y met la région email et
imessage y sont quand même de l'économie
réelle on dit l'économie réelle avant
tout la rigueur budgétaire
je reviens sur cette histoire des
fiscalités canton n'exonère une partie
des plus riches de ce pays de l'impôt a
au moment où elle le fmi lui-même et
christine lagarde qui est pas
bolchévique dit il faut que les plus
riches contribuent à ce que ces de
salubrité publique et que ça contribue à
la croissance de l'économie
on peut pas dire après économie réelle
dans les régions donc ce choix fiscal là
en haut de la pyramide sociale en haut
de la pyramide des revenus
il a des conséquences sur tout le reste
alors quelles réponses quand même une
fraction de tva qui serait la dynamique
pour les ressources des collectivités
c'est un très bon système ces parties où
il faut qu'on il faut qu'on continue
tanger la mort mais allons-y l'accord
des accords politiques vous l'avez
souligné
je sais que je suis plus cure politique
c'est pas du tout une posture politique
je vais vous dire allez vannes moi je
dis je discute avec tous les maires de
gauche de droite
on n'est pas dans une posture on n'est
pas contre le président mâcon
on n'est pas contre le gouvernement on
est dans un état d'esprit et on a
l'habitude françois baron un peu plus
que vos mères potter nous les maires on
est plutôt dans un état d'esprit en plus
dans un esprit territoire états et
territoires qu'on nous laisse pas tomber
quoi vraiment qu'on ne laisse pas tomber
quand on quand vous parlez dotation vous
dis tu c'est vrai que les dotations
c'est pas un bon système
avec la taxe d'habitation on va nous
remettre une dotation dire que d'un côté
on nous dit les notations séparent bons
et de l'autre côté avec la taxe
d'habitation on nous remet une dotation
mais pour autant vous êtes favorable à
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
pour sa population parce qu'il ya quand
même
à la base il ya quand même un but pour
la population alors attendez il ya deux
ans bloguer vue sur votre stand est
d'accord si on prend si on prend la
populace taxe d'habitation
elle est exactement sur la même assiette
que la taxe foncière si la taxe
d'habitation est injuste la taxe
foncière est injuste aussi si la taxe
d'habitation taxes foncières
elle va pas le supprimer pour tout le
monde si seulement c'est une injustice
fx foncière ça veut dire qu'il va encore
y avoir 20 % et qu'on accepte en france
qui est 20% d'injustice qui se fasse si
vous versez 2 et de viser correctement
mais en même temps vous vous comprenez
qu avec ce que vous dites est
difficilement pendables par les 80% de
la population qui vont plus avoir les
habitations mais explique qu'il faut
simplifier au lieu de prendre 100% prend
80 % dans les ehpad on va redonner de
l'argent pour que les gens soient
compensées de ce qu'ils n'ont pas de ce
qu'ils n'ont pas n'ont pas droit il a
entre temps que le visage et dans les
ehpad lui ne subissent pas de
conséquence négative c'est très
exactement ce que nous sommes en train
de préparer dans le projet de loi de
finances ce que je veux dire quand même
c'est que on parle des collectivités à
juste raison puisque c'est notre débat
mais parfois aussi d' des usagers par
ont aussi de la situation financière de
la population française toutes les
mesures et contrairement à ces
extrêmement extrêmement simpliste me
semble-t-il en tout cas de dire ben
gouvernement pour les riches
gouvernement pour ériger tracé très
belle des mesures qui sont offerts
partout
il ya des mesures qui sont en fait
favorables au monde économique au monde
de l'entreprise considérant qu' on peut
pas distribuer des richesses qui n'ont
pas été créées faut donc d'abord les
créer messieurs c'est pas plus compliqué
faut les créer et ensuite à temps qu'a
passé les distribuer la taxe
d'habitation fait aussi partie de ce
dispositif où vous avez raison c'est
sans aucun doute la taxe d'habitation
est injuste mais sans aucun doute elle
était injuste mais sans aucun doute on
doit reprendre une partie substantielle
des impôts locaux qui marche un peu sur
as raison pour laquelle vous l'avez
peut-être vu au gouvernement le premier
ministre vient de désigner alain richard
et dominique bur qu'on a bien connu il a
été préfet de la région bourgogne pour
faire une mission préparatoire au pacte
financier qui lie l'état et les
collectivités
ça veut dire aussi que le schéma n'est
pas terminé nous sommes encore dans ces
discussions
fort heureusement ce n'est pas d'un
claquement de doigt quelques se fera
trois points principaux la maîtrise des
dépenses locales comme ont fait ensemble
pour maîtriser les dépenses le cadre
partant du principe que l'état temps à
maîtriser lui-même ses propres dépenses
et qu'on a un objectif à 3 %
deuxième élément la refonte de la
fiscalité locale sans laquelle on peut
pas avancer sérieusement you can un
troisième un troisième élément le
financement la gestion des allocations
individuelles et aucun doute pas réservé
que plusieurs départements et une
difficulté il faut qu'on la bordent
cette difficulté il faut qu'on écoutait
des faucons ont 10 mai mais ce qui me
faisait clients bhl que vous voyez des
effets en discussion les élus c'est
effectivement une vraie concertation est
vrai que j'ai ans ça vous parliez tout à
l'heure des postures politiques
si on prend l'exemple du logement social
c'est pas une posture politique le monde
du logement social qui soit de gauche de
droite est aujourd'hui en révolte
complète par rapport au gouvernement qui
a pris sans concertation jus toute une
série de mesures qui ont un impact
extrêmement négatif sur l'économie
rappelle que logement social c'est 20 %
de l'activité du bâtiment en france et
en côte d'or et en bourgogne
et puis un impact sur le territoire
puisqu'il y aura beaucoup moins
d'investissements au service des
communes au service du logement dans les
communes de rénovation de construction
neuve du fait de ces mesures prises sans
concertation
on peut pas voir le discours que vous
avez des gens temps qui est tout à fait
intéressant et puis dans la réalité
c'est pas ça qui se perd est ce que vous
n'avez pas l'impression de parler
beaucoup du fonctionnement debout
si vite et pas parler beaucoup d'usagers
en fait quand il parlait du logement par
exemple locataire d'un antivirus pour
autant part de notre fonctionnement on
ne parle que des usagers et on parle des
entreprises moi j'ai visité une
entreprise à cluny
il ya quinze jours qui s'appelle oxo
elle fabrique des huisseries elle
travaille essentiellement pour les
bailleurs publics et les dirigeants de
l'entreprise mondiaux en partant s'il
vous plaît comme parlementaire
travailler sur cette question parce que
l'investissement que les bailleurs ne
réaliseront pas ce sont des marchés
compères 75% de l'investissement public
ce sont les collectivités bien entendu
je suis désolé durer très longtemps on
refera une réduction de 9 pour sur la
suisse et merci messieurs d'être venus
débattre c'est la fin de cette émission
bon dimanche
urbas
[Musique]